New York went through an incredible
really almost miraculous fix and now has
been ruined again effectively or is in
the process I should say being ruined so
when I grew up in New York City which is
early like let's say early 90s 1990 New
York had over 2200 murders okay people
go back and they always they say there's
no way you can check that statistic it
was 22 something uh over 2 000 murders
which when you think about what we're
looking at now in different cities I
mean New York got went from 2200 murders
Giuliani comes in there's this whole
change in the approach to to crime and
criminal justice and everything by the
time I'm graduating high school New York
is now looking at can we get below 300
murders think about that from 2200
people gunned down to in a decade or so
you're like can we get it to like two
250 275